welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is where
we break down all the latest movie news
recently release games TV shows and
comic books in this video we're going to
be going over one of the biggest
mysteries that has surrounded the Star
Wars saga since the release of the force
awakens back in 2015 that is the true
identity of Rey's parents throughout
this video I'm going to be breaking down
the best fan theories as well as what
the recently released leaks reveal about
the character's true lineage due to the
nature of this video there is
potentially heavy spoilers here and
whilst all leaks like this should be
taken with a pinch of salt if they turn
out to be true then it may ruin the
movie for you I'll leave those leaks to
last so if you just want to stick with
the fan theories I'll give you another
heads-up before we get to them anyway
without the way I just want to give a
huge thank you for clicking this video
now let's get into our breakdown of who
raised parents are okay so the first
theory is that Rey's parents are indeed
nobodies that abandoned err on jakku
this is due to the line that kylo says
in the force awakens in which the
character states they were filthy junk
traders sold you off for drinking money
they're dead in a pauper's grave in the
jakku desert you have no place in this
story you come from nothing whilst this
is definitely likely and the evidence is
there to support it in a recent
interview with ABC JJ Abrams said the
following when discussing her lineage I
will say that we knew going into this
that this movie it had to be a
satisfying conclusion and we were well
aware that the discussion surrounding
Rey's parents is one of the things
that's been out there I don't want to
say what happens in episode 8 didn't
happen we have honored that but I will
say that there's more to the story than
you've seen so it does indeed seem like
they may be sticking with the original
point but across in the last Jedi but
they will be building upon it in several
interesting ways we have seen throughout
the Star Wars franchise in the case of
Anakin that it is possible for paupers
and peasants to become massively
important in the galaxy and the force
isn't prejudiced when it comes to
picking people that have great power
with it raised parents could indeed be
nobodies and she could just happen to be
lucky
able to wield the force in the way that
she does without any training due to her
natural abilities however if this does
turn out to be true it seems slightly
against JJ's original vision and we can
guess from the comments that he made
that the Creator does indeed have a few
tricks up his sleeve I thought I'd put
this in first as it's pretty much the
one that we all know about but the list
definitely gets more interesting the
further we get into it the next theory
that seems to be picking up a lot of
steam is that Rey is actually Han Solo's
daughter but to make matters more
complicated she's not Leia and is in
fact the child of Kira from solo a Star
Wars story the theory states that Solo
and Kira had a child together and after
the latter got in too deep with
gangsters she fled to jakku with her new
partner where they were eventually
tracked down and killed thus leaving Rey
on her own this makes a lot of sense and
definitely ties in with some of the lore
thus far retro actively making solo a
better movie and Rey more tied to the
franchise than we previously thought if
Rey's parents were indeed paupers and
junk traders then this lines up with
Kira who definitely lived a life of
poverty and crime
Kira also has no qualms about cutting
people off even the ones that she loves
and in solo a Star Wars story we get
just how cutthroat that she is when she
abandons Han in the close of the movie
this theory would also add a lot of
weight as to why Han took such a shine
to Rey on their first meeting and who
knows maybe he saw something in her that
reminded him of the woman he lost all
those years ago however it would mean
that Kira was either pregnant and gave
birth to a child before she met back up
with Han in the movie or that the two
bumped into each other once more after
the events of the film if this is the
case then it means that Rey and kylo
actually half sister and brother and
that kylo actually killed her true
father making him a much bigger threat
in her eyes I don't know if this theory
will turn out to be true but it actually
sounds like a pretty cool one that
nicely ties the spin-off movie into the
main universe it would be devastating
for Rey to know that she actually had
found her father but was robbed of this
relationship by kylo and out of all of
the theories that are out there
is one of my favorites mirroring this is
the theory that she may even be the
secret child of Han and Leia and this
would explain how she is so powerful
with the force there's actually
precedents for this already in the Star
Wars universe as in the original
expanded works that were released before
the sequel saga wipe the slate clean Han
and Leia had two children one named
Jason and the other named Jaina who were
both strong Jedi Jason ended up turning
to the dark side and this put the two
into conflict in a battle that spanned
the galaxy where this falls down now is
that Leia has spent a lot of time with
Rey and Shirley due to a force
sensitivity she would begin to suspect
that they were related
kylo mentions nothing of a long-lost
sister and the two parents don't really
seem like the kind of people who would
ditch their daughter especially with how
much effort they both put into saving
kylo from walking down a dark path this
theory would be fun but I think it's a
little too tied to the original series
and it doesn't really feel like the big
twist that there should be for the
character who is went so long agonizing
over who her true parents are whilst all
the theories mentioned thus far have
been things that would be cool little
reveals the final theory may just blow
your mind now it did promise to give you
all the heads up before we got into the
leaks part of the video so if you made
it this far but one to duck out then
thanks for watching but now's the time
to go are you still here okay good so
the leaks that were recently released by
reddit user Jedi PAC sis drop a massive
spanner in the works for Rey the user
has got numerous leaks right thus far
including c-3po s red eyes long before
the previous trailer released as well as
the return of Palpatine before we ever
heard that instantly recognizable cackle
in the trailer anyway the user has said
that in the upcoming film kylo maintains
that while her parents are nobodies
her grandparents more specifically her
grandfather isn't in a big twist of fate
kylo tells Rey that she is the
granddaughter of Palpatine and that he
has been watching her for a long time
this explains his interest in bringing
the random nobody from jakku into the
fold and also why she is so strong with
the force it also adds weight to why
when she was training to be a Jedi
her mind tended to wander to the dark
side and this may be her grandfather
influence this is a theory that has
floated about online now for the past
four years and it definitely seems to
have a lot of fans behind it everything
from her Imperial accent to her
lightsaber fighting style seems to line
up with things that he would have
instilled in his children who then
instilled it into her Palpatine is
definitely the kind of guy to cast his
offspring to the side if they didn't
live up to expectation and perhaps one
of Rey's parents who was the child of
old Pappy was disowned after they were
clearly unconnected from the force maybe
similar to how many theorized that
Palpatine manipulated the midi-chlorians
to create life like he did with Anakin
Palpatine could have done the same with
race mother and therefore created a new
extremely powerful Jedi who he sees as
the next one to carry the torch the leak
also states that Palpatine's plan and
the rise of skywalker is to build anger
and rey to the point that she lashes out
and takes him down in the same stroke
taking his place as the ruler of the
empire and a new dark force in the
universe this is backed up by images
that show rey as a sith whilst they are
definitely a vision of what could come
to pass
it makes sense that Palpatine would be
manipulating her in this way to turn to
the dark side
he clearly has no qualms about dying in
order to create a new Dark Lord and in
Return of the Jedi we watched as he
taunted Luke in order to get him to
strike him down and take his place it's
definitely a really interesting idea and
if this is the big reveal in the movie
then I have to admit I won't be
disappointed I've already done a full
breakdown of all of the leaks if this is
piqued your interest yeah sign me up to
the idea of pimp up a teen that went
through the galaxy having kids in order
to bring them up to be rulers of the
universe either that Akira JJ anyone
will do just please don't ruin Star Wars
any more we are begging you now
obviously and love to hear your thoughts
on who you think Rey's parents are and
which one of these theories that you
like the best comment below and let me
know and if you enjoy this video then
please give it a thumbs up and make sure
you check out my breakdown of how
Palpatine survived the ending of The
Return of the Jedi and how he will come
back for the rise of Skywalker we
over all the possible theories and
evidence to support them so it's
definitely worth checking out if you
want to know more you want to come chat
to me after the video that make sure you
follow me on twitter at definition
whitey or head over to my discord server
which will be linked in the description
below those are the best ways to keep up
to date with all the latest videos in
the channel so hopefully I see you over
there very soon we're also giving away a
free copy of the marble phase 3 part 1
boxer on blu-ray which contains Civil
War Doctor Strange homecoming Ragnarok
and more and all you have to do to be in
with a chance of winning is like the
video make sure that you subscribe to
the channel and leave your thoughts and
Ray's parents in the comment section
below the winners gonna be chosen on the
15th of November and the set will be
shipped out from then to ever get
surprised it's the best of luck to
everyone who takes part this is the
channel for people who are mad into
movies so if that's the kind of thing
you like hit subscribe thanks again for
taking the time to watch this I've been
definition you've been the best I'll see
you next time take care peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]